what's going on more I sit down I'm good
how are you I I mean what's going on
with you 20 seasons of this huh
when was that with anthrax the band is
that right yeah that's so funny yeah I
remember Schmoll I remember I remember
you have live performances here yeah we
do from time to time here still every
now and then this is Andrew Schultz by
the way how you doing
really yeah yeah yes Sam right here
where's John I mean Jim Jim is he's in
LA is he still working for you or is he
oh yeah I don't know he still works here
he's just she what he went to the Emmys
[Laughter]
shooting thing I heard enough for the
he's that cool I don't know that he was
nominated this year really but you'll
get there he'll get there yeah well we
were nominated too
last year I was gonna ask you as you're
sure every nominee that was and I I
don't go to those things knows no
because we always lose so no I mean
years and years ago when I started this
show a Current Affair yeah so I was
working for Rupert Murdoch yeah and the
show was nominated and I was the host
and it was a big deal and Rupert said I
don't think you ought to go to these
things we're more interested in getting
viewers not Awards I think he's thought
about that ever since I mean it's free
jeez that's that's where the bread and
butter is so it's the Daytime Emmys
right that was the daytime so who gets
who gets you know beat you for Eleanor I
mean you've created you know created
yours onra right like you you deserve
something here I mean come on
yes Sam I mean you know you'd give your
life do you ever I was I was talking
about you earlier do you lose your faith
in humanity at any point
oh really well now you look on it Sam
well I have to ask you because like
we're looking at the episode scheduled
for this week this is the big season
premiere week today today is the
season for me big one right you got to
find more aren t you it must have been
DNA well you something come on this
season yeah this week yeah today being
one of them three of your first five
shows right our DNA shows here's the
father when you realize they're terrific
I bet they're amazing I'm gonna watch
them we put don't you think we would put
the best on the inaugural week you'd
have to you'd have to but like when you
realize I didn't know that you did not
DNA yes episode so I tell you then I go
like a go like three of the five shows
and then Schultz goes so you mean to
tell me that there are Maury shows that
are not the intention if I tuned
we got lie detector shows you want some
lie detector about you know the father
no well it could be but lie detector
about are you cheating on me it's great
as long as it has to do in that it's in
that space I need infidelity these
relationship plans experience taking the
archetype you've put it into a nice
daytime television show of course that's
all you are
I was what Hilde we act actually killed
what we call consider to be daytime soap
operas because it took them six months
something I can get through in 12
minutes each story is unique it is one
of them one of the episode titles from
this week is something to the effect of
in Travis you might have to correct me
if I'm wrong here but it was something
to the effect of like which I'm a
YouTube star who's the father of my baby
or size that it we're actually actually
we're going to do something because
social media is so important right so we
are now going to take YouTube stars yeah
you know I get a million hits sure a
million
whatever and put them on the show and
put them through lie-detector but I had
no idea there was paternity Wars Oh in
the YouTube sphere of course everywhere
everything so here's a here's what's
going on this week okay one of them
my sister cheated with three men that's
not your baby
looking forward to that one I'm not so
my sister cheated with three men then so
that's a brother who's defending his
sister right against a guy right who the
guys like that's my baby and the
brothers like know my sister's slept
with way more guys than just you exactly
you need to get out of here right that's
a great show okay this next one is I
think this might I think today's I think
tomorrow's is I have a secret I've been
dating you both for a year that's right
I mean that's that's pretty selfish and
[Laughter]
the girlfriend doesn't know he's been
with the wife that to me so he spends
days with one of the women and nights
with the other and he decided he thinks
to himself you know where I'm gonna
finally tell them on the Maury show I
think the best thing to do
yeah I want to unburden themselves right
in front of a 78 year old man you got
Wednesday Wednesday show okay tell me
Wednesday for women seven babies tested
yep which man is the father that's the
title of an episode that's lit for women
for women seven babies tested well
they're not all the same story which man
is the father but still you're sitting
there and you're like wait about four
different stories but you're like I'm
gonna get to go through seven paternity
test on one show exactly how do you not
tune in right how can you not okay and
let me tell you what is the clincher
yeah yeah from the first moment I ever
started doing DNA shows yeah so my
producers you know the way they briefed
you before the show what are you going
to do it
and they go through the story and here's
the result and I said I don't want to
know the result what uh I'm one of the
surprise as the guests the audience the
live audience the audience at home
because they followed this they're all
of a sudden yeah in fact guess what
Shaquille O'Neal it's been said watches
my show every day and bets with his
friends on who the father I would love
to know yeah I would love to know if
he's ever I mean think about that I mean
they they bet on balls and strikes and
things like that and in baseball
absolutely these balls right right
exactly
hey Anthony I got great news for you we
were talking to Maury Povich over here
do you know Maury I do okay we were
talking to Mari and you know what he
told me he said that uh he goes sit down
make yourself comfortable he said that
many people that he encounters Shaquille
O'Neal being one of them
Gamble's say on who's the father on the
Maury that's probably one of the
greatest things I've ever this is gonna
be sad but when I was little and I used
to watch it my and my grandmother used
to like she's like right I'm gonna go to
the bathroom real quick I used like off
this guy's [ __ ] definitely the father
if I put like $25 on it of course well
it's right into it okay there Thursday
show Thank You Anthony
you're welcome Thursday show is a mom
the test will prove your husband is a
cheater oh yeah that's the that's the
lie detector show so that's like the
daughter right and she's saying your
husband so it happened to be the
daughters saying her stepfather
she should have never been with him
right he was a dog to start with right
right and then finally the big Friday
show is this Schultz this is gonna be
your favorite one okay I am a YouTube
celebrity but not your baby's father hi
that's great
we're bringing this guy on who's the big
celebrity oh and by the way who's a
pewdiepie the end the no and a reason
and the reason the reason is that he
thinks that all she wants is his YouTube
fame that's why she is accusing him of
being the fun father of her child right
and I'm going how much money do you make
on YouTube who's the guy can you say who
the guy no I can't remember that has to
be a secret mainly because I have no
idea but do you so this isn't these are
real stories right cuz there was no no
no don't go there
yes we check these stories out I mean my
producers we have seven production teams
yeah they all act as like a mini
newsroom they check these stories out
they talk to people in their town they
talked to all the relatives and the
friends and then nobody's because if
enough I was very disappointed when I
found out that that when Jerry Springer
Show kind of came clean that this was an
entertainment show I was like Jerry Buss
twenty-five years and and Jerry Jerry is
is very truthful he admits his show is
wrestling right right right right but
your show is the real deal so that's why
I asked you about the question about
losing faith in humanity when you
realize that like you can fill this year
out year after year after year that
there are this many compounds
Sam Sam with paternity issues is part of
the American fabric right you understand
this is not some weird somewhat right it
crosses all areas it's a rainbow
coalition right one ethnic group or
another now you're right it's every in
fact I I rest my case on this but yeah
four or five years ago the New York
Times Sunday magazine came out with a
story that said there's a survey 10% of
all kids are with the wrong father Wow
how's that and you're there to clear
that up okay
leave in you're married I see you have a
ring oh yeah I'm married to the most
beautiful most I think credible and and
and the best journalist in the Western
world Connie Chung oh I didn't know that
you guys are married oh yeah oh no do
you guys may for a long time they don't
know I've haven't been keeping up on his
marriage so do you guys believe in
fidelity why not well I don't know no no
no we dated a long time before we got
married yeah and it wasn't exclusive so
you were out there dropping dick off
well I was that how your fur to it my
wife would say my wife would say I I
never knew the last names of the women I
dated she was dating Hollywood stars
what can I tell you what do you know any
of the stars that she dated yes but I'm
not telling you did you ever get even in
the beginning now not so much but in the
beginning were you jealous of these
celebrities I would be if probably know
publicly now what got you you're you're
you're less jealous if you're not in a
committed relationship at the time so
right but I would think that like I
would be in a relationship with this
person who had dated celebrities and
stuff and at some point like we're
committed now and everything's all good
but then those things creep into your
head like ah you'd see the person on
television or in a movie you've been
there Sam what no I just think about it
a lot you do I think about it a lot well
guess what what that's how you create
tolerance 20mins you got this jovial
nature it's great do you think we need
to have like a like a Dancing with the
Stars thing that you host as well
they've talked to me about that before
but actually dancing I mean yeah but I
what about paternity Dancing with the
Stars can I go with those be celebrities
what the heck
guess what was a great dancer I bet we
don't have to go into your private life
right I want to know was there ever a
conversation like Connie is this great
news woman yes
then you do what you do right was there
ever a conversation about being a credit
to journalism questioning well first of
all the validity I start I started in
journalism and I worked there for like
20 years
okay journalist but here's this is this
is the picture you have to understand so
when we get invited let's say to a key
social event
let's say it one of those East Side
apartments that people have and I go
there with my wife and all these media
types you know hover over Connie right
and just you know how come you're not on
these days and we'd love you so much you
got to go back on you got to do
something you got to do this and I'm
going I'm sitting there with my arms
folded and I'm going [ __ ] on this I go
to the kitchen and I'm beloved by
everybody in the kitchen go were you
celebrated now where you're tolerated
yes and you get this great kick to
because like all these people are hope
they don't realize that you got to be
raking in millions of money no that had
to drive you crazy when Judge Judy comes
out and she's like yeah I'm the richest
woman in television you're like what
Judge Judy she is but I under play it
you do oh yeah help the only people who
know much how much money I make are the
people at NBC who are pissed off
because it's not like you could throw
because here's what's great about this
is like the fact that you are not the
father you are the father is your
catchphrase right paternity tests are
now associated with Mari so it's not
like they could just take the concept
and move it to another shelves alert I'm
boy why don't you sell pregnancy tests
you need a branded pregnancy test think
about that who else would you buy I'm
not gonna bite of all if you think of
all the names executive producer had
this great idea Paul for labor okay and
this was the idea you know can you
imagine all the names I have to memorize
on the show and babies names and this is
amazing crowd OHS names right seven
babies on one show so we want to put put
out a mari show book of baby names you
know what do the pregnancy you don't
really like about the book of baby names
oh my it is because it says it out loud
instead of one strip for positive Emily
I say you are a father this is how we
make money let's go to partnership I
want to do it here's what I like about
the about the baby name book is that it
is so distasteful like it really does
once you're looking at names of babies
like it's this warmth and you're you
definitely keeping the baby and it's
like we're building this family think
about all the names Maureen think about
all the creative names I have to learn
on the show a lot of syllables a lot of
syllables when okay so when you real
have a lot of Franks when you realize
right that that there are men that will
just do these amazing dances right when
they find out that they're not the
father are you sitting there like oh my
god this is a goldmine we have to do
this for everybody dance when they oh I
got one guy one guy did like three
backflips right right on the stage right
in the front of the poor woman I mean I
got very upset at that did you yeah
oh and of course how about the the women
you know they always seemed when when
they're unfortunately the guy they're
accused
is not the father they run off the stage
they throw themselves on my sofa
backstage right and I go console them
right and tell them you know don't worry
it's an honest mistake and will bring
back anybody you want if you want to
find out the father of your child and
all that yeah so Tyler Perry calls me up
and he's doing a Medea movie and Medea
is going on the show my show to find out
whether whether this guy is the father
of her child
uh-huh she reenacts the entire running
office tape it runs on the stage falls
down on the sofa one of my shining
moments we had you realize that you you
created something that is a cultural
icon yeah for better or worse I know I
kind of backed into it but what can I
tell you yeah it really is it really is
incredible do you plan on just doing
this for as long as possible I'm gonna
do it as long as it's sold an NBC keep
selling it I mean I I thought I was on
my way to assisted living but but they
seemed looking at me like these nuts we
had this interaction I have no clue you
were coming in today really surprised
and I'm so happy yeah just it's great to
see this side of you men who did an
Instagram account for you just showing
you smiling happy all the time enjoy
your life with Connie Chung hanging out
with the waitstaff at the Eastside
dinners have you ever had a person who
comes on right they get humiliated
because that happens and I say [ __ ] you
Mari like you did this to me you know
it's very interesting no really no
because well they'll say for instance on
a lie-detector test that tests not right
I'm gonna retake the test I said the
test is 90% no this is not my child that
that paternity test is wrong I said
that's 99.9 percent you know and you
know those guys who keep denying denying
denying usually my producers backstage
talk to them and we're filming it and
finally they come clean
yeah I guess I'd want to start all over
and they say they're gonna be good
fathers and we check up on them yet do
you
within a year later we'll do it we'll go
and say did this guy really and some do
and some don't
how often do you keep up the everyone
that comes on everyone but right because
there's so many the ones that are really
good stories I do how many shows this
season 135 I'd sees per season yes
135 shows yes original shows so how do
you what's the shooting schedule like on
that well are you doing Connecticut yes
yeah Stanford at the rich forum it's a
big radio and and Springer and I and
Wilkos all do it in the same I've seen
it's got the neon thing out right
exactly
up there I've been up to Stanford okay
so I study on Wednesday mm-hmm I taped
three shows on Thursday and two on
Friday oh my god you're doing five shows
in two days so you talked about
memorizing like names and things my
Alzheimer's check very like you're very
I couldn't believe when I read that you
were 78 like it is just working my wife
says no work what do you mean I'm not
like certain members of the Trump family
[Laughter]
no Botox no little procedures so it's a
girls run back they are convinced the
guy's the father they really believe oh
absolutely yeah so now they have to deal
with the disappointment of him not being
the father and feeling like a [ __ ]
right yeah and then coming back another
time
most likely to test somebody else I love
that they treat this like the doctor's
office well I guess I got to go back
tomorrow and you know she feels
embarrassed but at the same time I think
you're brave and courageous that you
want to fight look you know as well as I
do you get two parents in a home that
child's got a heck of a lot better
chance the course yeah right so and
that's why they're doing it right so you
know all power to him yeah
where was I going with what a minute ago
right before you're asking about I just
really want to know I'm hotter also do
that run that's the fastest 40-yard dash
in America very good yeah they should we
should have like an Olympic event for
more and some of them do it in heels
I read an interview that you just
recently did the Donald Trump used to
call you and give you show ideas is this
right he what he did was he used to
watch Donald did Donald did course he
did what successful businessman is
watching out gambling watching for years
I love this idea that he's not he's not
sitting there watching CNBC he's not
watching like the finance back then he's
got I think I was in his office maybe
once or twice he's got a he had a bank
he's got his own stock ticker he got
everything right but he's got Mariana TV
but but he did I mean he was watching my
show and we bring this girl on and she
was suffering from a very rare disease
and he called up and he wanted to help
and so he wrote a check
Wow so I mean there's that side of him
the chassis sees something you know I
tell you there's it that says two things
number one he can be a nice guy but
number two he's highly influenced by
television I just love how much Donald
Trump loves TV like I was reading a I
was reading a story today about a guy
named Tucker Carlson who yeah
conservative thing and he and he was
talking to Trump and he believes that
Trump uses TV as more an accurate view
of the temper of the country than
polling TV that what happens on TV right
TV ratings what they say on TV more an
accurate reflection of what's happening
in the country you know I you are in
polling you're the number one I would
think person to ask about that based on
your experience do you think that you've
got a better gauge of America based on
your television show
well I mean there's no doubt that I I
know a lot of issues because of my
television show something a lot of
people a lot of people feel yeah
maybe there's something he's a percent
right to not believe in the polling
after what happened to him well that's
true oh do you believe in the polling
who reported on the polling say yet who
reported on the polling media the TV TV
reported on it but it wasn't the people
that were watching the TV so I think
that's what you're saying right it's
like 50 million people are watching one
program gotcha trust those for those
demographics I mean I want to tell you
when he was doing The Apprentice he knew
all about ratings he right I'm telling
you he he knew exist
I mean he was I mean he was pretty
nimble when it came to TV yeah I mean in
the apprentice is a great show I loved
that show oh she bit me that he would
pick guess and like a startled which
people he wanted on the show speaking
who would rate ah so he cared about
ratings more than anything else
hmm so you think he used this TV
experience to help him at least I don't
doubt it
really and I think I mean when you think
about experience you know we always want
to think about the experience that our
presidents have yeah his number one
experience yeah do you still do the
phobia shows once in a while still but
they still I mean to this day the pickle
lady it's hard to beat was the woman who
was scared to death of pickles okay so
we brought a barrel of pickles to get
away from the barrel of pickles what's
the what's the brain brainstorming
session like when you're like okay how
do we get we got a woman who's afraid of
we got a women who's afraid of pickles
we're gonna bring a barrel of pickles
onstage how do we spin this so it's like
we're helping her honey well because
we've got to see her in her worst moment
right we've got to bring her all the way
down I see the bottom eyes
barrel in order to get an expert to go
work with her so that later on she could
put her hand in the barrel pull out a
pickle write it write it see ya see Wow
changing lives I'll tell you this
there's a comedian his name is Jim
Jefferies you know Jim Jefferies right
Charles yes of course he is and you
should try to get him on your show
because he's terrified of bananas oh
okay like if you have a banana in the
room with Jim Jefferies he'll run out of
the room
why terrified of them but why don't know
it's just one of those psychological
things he's just we had one woman who
was scared of cotton ball I remember her
he was and so we dressed up an intern
they brought a cotton ball man to go I
mean it seems like it's cruel and
unusual no how do you stop yourself from
laughing like this you don't you don't
happen the moment the moment the most
laughable moment on air was I'm doing a
show with a lie detector
this woman is accusing her boyfriend of
cheating on her and disappearing at one
time on three different occasions and he
comes on and says I have the you have to
understand this I was kidnapped and put
into the trunk of a car on three it's
very good I can't believe people say how
can you put up with that I said are you
kidding
great yeah you know what do you do you
live in Connecticut no where do you live
I live right in the middle of the city
oh I say
- well then I Drive okay I Drive up
there yeah twice a week to do the show
and I like to drive everybody well you
must have a driver I'm a driver right I
Drive right you drive I Drive you know
30 million a year not a chance
I'll tell you why you like to drive a
lot of money you save on a driver that's
going right in the pocket well listen
that's going gets upset all that driver
money goes to making more cotton ball
suit